welcome back to the rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division just gave
vision both his biggest threat and his
possible lifeboat to a future in the mcu
in the form of white vision at least
that's what we're calling them
a secondary sentient weapon built by
hayward using vision's corpse parts
and wanda's magic from that drone that
she told them to keep out of her yard
now posing a threat to wanda in the
scarlet vision
that's what i'm gonna call him the hex
vision that wanda created with her mind
stone amplified chaos magic but also
still apparently tangible enough to
trigger vibranium decay sensors on the
outside
so the two visions to what my favorite
breakfast date
these are confusing times and there is
an equally confusing history with white
vision in the comics and i'm gonna
explain
what this vision versus vision battle
will probably look like in the one
division finale episode and what white
vision's arrival means for paul betany's
employment status
so in one division white vision is the
product of project
cataract sword director tyler hayward's
secret sentient weapons project
sometime after vision's death and
wakanda and infinity war presumably in
the last three years because that's when
hayward took over
sword from the late maria rambo hayward
got his hands on vision's desaturated
remains and
shifted sword's focus to reanimated
vision into a superhero synthesized that
he could control
now sure you could try to theorize a
deeper agenda or hidden identity by
hayward
as a form of ultron or the grim reaper
or mephisto
no i don't think so folks i'm chained to
the freaking engine of the mephisto
train
but not everything is mephisto just to
most things hayward is just another
government a-hole
seeing superheroes as controllable
assets kind of like what tony stark
hoped to do with the iron legion
certainly there's a thematic parallel
with the ultron disaster
but really it's a mistake that every god
player falls into hayward likely hoped
that wanda could use her mysterious
magic
and bond with vision to reboot his parts
but when she didn't do that
and made the town of westview new jersey
disappear off the map
hayward sent in monica rambo after
updating sword's front desk security
so that monica would fly a drone into
the anomaly
so that maybe hayward could snatch some
of wanda's yummy yummy magic
but then unfortunately for hayward
monica herself got sucked in
and no other probes came back out with
usable magic
until the 80s stark drone something that
was already in the 80s form
didn't need to be rewritten by the
reality so in order to be disabled out
of a weapon that would hurt wanda
needed to be coded with this chaos magic
in order to
keep it disabled giving hayward the
synthesized fuel source that he needed
while as going on hayward lied to monica
saying wanda did steal visions parts
in order to one make wanda look like
villain and to hide his own possession
of those parts and his whole plan to
weaponize them into project cataract
white vision now this whole plot does
reflect
a bit of how white vision came about in
the comics he comes from the 1989
vision quest arc of the west coast
avenger comics after vision had
previously taken over the government
nuclear weapons arsenal
as avengers chairman and then
relinquished it but those government
agents were still pretty freaked out
so while wanda and vision were married
she wakes up one day to find vision gone
and then later finds out that the
government had kidnapped and dismantled
vision's body oh and fun fact we later
find out that those government forces
were
actually being manipulated by immortus
one of the forms of the time traveling
villain
kang the conqueror now kang is showing
up in ant-man the wasp quantomania
and rumor is he could first appear in
loki
if kang slash immortus is behind hayward
here that would be
nuts though not as nuts as hayward being
ultron or morphisto let's let's keep our
insanity in check if we can anyway in
the comics hank pam tries to reassemble
vision remember hank pym built ultron in
ultron built vision so he's kind of like
his grand grader and ultron built vision
using the android body of the original
human torch and the brain waves of
wonder man simon williams but
now williams refuses to give his brain
waves to resurrect vision because he
said that it felt like his soul was
ripped out so without those brain waves
and with the irreparable tissue damage
vision returns white and soulless two
words that also describe
this guy and by the way this is all
going down as wanda realizes that her
sons billy and tommy are pieces of
mephisto's soul and that agatha harkness
has been brainwashing her so wanda and
white vision
separate now later in the comics vision
does get a new red body from an
alternate dimension
and brain waves from the deceased son of
miles lipton
scientist alex lipton and then the
brainwaves of simon williams do return
and merge with those as well
and thus through the magic of comic book
[ __ ] vision walks again
but based on what we are seeing in
wandavision that same kind of [ __ ]
might bring paul bettany vision truly
back from the dead in the mcu
you know it's nice to see these two
characters that are clearly just meant
for each other a match made in heaven
you know what the odds of you finding
the perfect match for you
are pretty low just like the odds of you
grabbing a random mattress and it being
perfect for you are also very low
well quit sleeping on an ill-fitting
mattress and get yourself a personalized
helix mattress
thank you to helix for sponsoring this
episode helix mattresses are made in
america and shipped to your door with
free
delivery free returns in a 100 night
sleep trial to choose a mattress helix
made a quiz that takes just two minutes
and matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you
if you like a mattress that's really
soft or firm or if you sleep on your
side or on your stomach or if you sleep
really hot with helix there is a
specific mattress for your unique taste
i took the quiz and i got matched with
the dusk
looks helix mattress because i wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool
and i sleep great on my helix mattress
helix was awarded the number one best
overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
wired magazine and apartment therapy
just go to helixsleep.com rockstars take
their two-minute sleep quiz and they'll
match you
to a customized mattress for the best
sleep of your life and
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they'll even pick it up for
you if you don't love it helix is
offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
rockstars that's helix sleep.com
rockstars for up to 200
off and two free pillows paul bettany
himself indicated that his
employment with marvel studios is
ongoing beyond one division
from when he played coy about fan
theories about mephisto
this one that mentions uh mephisto
i can't speak to right now
because i'm worried about getting
fired our editor heidra john pointed out
that
since betany had wrapped on wanovision
by the time this interview was recorded
for him to be worried about getting
fired would suggest that he is still
under contract to appear in a future
marvel title now he could have said sued
or
fired for violating my nda but no he
said fired which is essentially the fear
of a guy who still has his job so yes
this one division finale is clearly
setting up a vision bowl
white vision versus scarlet vision i'm
gonna give the edge to scarlet vision
because
he has something to fight for and he is
on his home turf
he is such a product of the hex that he
begins to crumble the moment he steps
out of the hex which actually does give
white vision a tactic here
white vision's goal might be to drag
scarlet vision out of the hex like a
wrestler throwing his opponent out of
the ring
just imagine white vision shoving
scarlet vision's face into that hex wall
as he's screaming
but step away from this for a second
let's imagine if one division does end
house of m style
with wanda leaving this dimension
escaping into a new hex reality where
she
and her boys can live in peace alongside
other mutants
including her real brother aaron taylor
johnson pietro
a house of m would vision want to live
in that
lie last they talked he seemed pretty
betrayed by her
so wanda might instead grant vision a
way to
live on in his home reality the prime
mcu away from her as she leaves it
by merging visions consciousness with
the white vision body
a vision from a separate reality not
unlike the comics now even though wanda
can seemingly create vibranium out of
thin air i don't think she would be able
to give him a completely new mind stone
in his head when he's outside the hex
seems like she can create a mind stone
in that hex but outside that hex the
marine stone has been atomized still
though she is a nexus bean with magic
derived from the mind stone
and her weekly woos could be converted
into synthesiod fuel from that drone on
the outside
so using that logic wanda could charm
something else as a replacement battery
perhaps the gem in her engagement ring
she could even
engrave a little heart in it like the
heart that vision wrote on the deed and
the heart that began all this on the
calendar
this way as wanda moves on into a house
of m universe one that could get
revisited a multiverse madness
vision could walk once more in the prime
mcu longing for his love the good witch
who gave this
tin man his heart back ooh by the way if
you have not already this unusual
couple's shirt
plus its purple counterpart are about to
sell out this is your last chance to get
these you just gotta go to
newrockstarsmerch.com
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eddie avas follow me rockstar subscribe
to new rockstars for everything wanna
vision thank you for watching
[Music]
you